how do you describe distance
with a number obviously
length
but what about describing distance in
relation to a coordinate grid like on a
map
well then you need two numbers
the lengths along the grid
as well as a formula relating those
lengths to your distance
now what about if your grid is skewed
well
then you need to specify a third number
for your description
the angle of the skew
and then modify your formula
let's extend this by asking what if your
grid is three-dimensional
then you have not only three grid
lengths but also three angles that can
be skewed independently
and so you arrive at six possible
numbers to describe distance
now let's push it even further by asking
what if your grid isn't
three-dimensional but rather
four-dimensional with a slightly more
abstract formula for distance defined on
it
well
then you need ten numbers
and it's these ten numbers that are so
crucial for describing our
spatio-temporal reality
this is dialect with
the space-time metric
consider two nearby locations on a map
how can we describe the distance between
them
we can start by expressing such a
distance in terms of the map coordinates
dx squared plus dy squared
but this won't yield the true distance
between those locations because
for a map of something like the earth
where a curved surface has been
projected onto a flat one
an interval dx or dy here on the map
doesn't represent the same distance as
an interval dx or dy elsewhere on the
map
moreover the true angle between dx and
dy may not be 90 degrees
to calculate the actual distance
represented by this coordinate distance
on the map
you need a metric
or more specifically a metric tensor
essentially a sophisticated bar scale
the metric tensor tells us the true
surface distances along our coordinate
intervals
and the true surface angles between our
coordinate axes
for every small patch of our map
with the size of these patches going to
zero in their infinitesimal limit
since a surface can be mapped in many
different ways
different maps will require different
metrics
this robinson projection for instance
preserves neither lengths areas nor
angles
and so requires three distinct numbers
at each patch to describe earth's
geometry
the metric tensor thus relates the
geometry of a map
to the geometry of a surface being
depicted by that map
in our prior videos we demonstrated this
visually showing how by first cutting a
map into many small pieces
instructions from the metric tensor
could be used to resize those pieces in
order to fit them to a curved surface
but now let's consider a different type
of map
a space-time map
instead of two nearby locations
consider two nearby space-time events
can we describe a notion of distance
between them
there are two answers to this question
the special relativity answer and the
general relativity answer
special relativity says yes we can
that any two points in space and time
can be related via a single number
known as their space-time separation
interval
we write this special distance as a
pythagorean relation between the dt
squared and the dx squared
only now we swap the plus sign for a
minus one
it's no longer our intuitive notion of
distance
but it shares some common features with
physical distance
namely that of being an invariant real
quantity
but only so long as we're sticking to
inertial frames of reference and local
systems
but general relativity trades in both
non-inertial frames of reference and in
global systems
so this answer gets turned on its head
and we find that if we try to describe
the space-time distance between two
nearby world events on an observer's
space-time map
via expressing it through the
coordinates dt squared minus dx squared
we will run into the same problem we had
with describing physical distance on a
map of the earth
that is an interval dx or dt here on the
diagram may not represent the same
space-time distance as an interval dx or
dt elsewhere on the diagram
moreover the true space-time angle
between dx and dt
may not be an orthogonal one
this is because the geometry of our
space-time map which is flat doesn't
match up with the geometry of this
surface that our map is depicting
but let's back up a minute
what surface exactly are we depicting
with a space-time diagram
you might think a space-time map is a
map of well space and time
in fact we said as much in our last
video making a map
a map of space and time
but this is rather imprecise
it's like calling a map of the earth a
map of latitude and longitude
indeed a space-time diagram is not
really a map of space and time at all
but rather a map of world events
which are merely ordered via space and
time
how this ordering occurs is
observer-dependent and so each
space-time map belongs to a particular
observer or network of observers who
based off of light signals transmitted
throughout the universe assign a
quadruplet of coordinates three for
space and one for time
to each world event which transpires
since in making this projection the
observer assumes that time and space are
everywhere independent dimensions
this projection or map
has everywhere a flat geometry
locally such a projection will hold
in their immediate vicinity the
space-time intervals and observer
measures will always be accurate
but if they want to know what local
space-time intervals observers who are
located elsewhere will measure
they will need to supplement their
space-time map with a metric
to formulate such a metric the theory of
differential geometry tells us that
if we cut out a portion of a curved
surface
so long as this portion is small enough
to be considered flat the only
operations we need to worry about
performing upon it
in order to fit it to our map
are the operations
of stretching
and or skewing
therefore we can regard the local
coordinates on a surface piece
as being stretched and or skewed
relative to the map coordinates
algebraically
this translates into an ability to
express the surface coordinate intervals
which will label dx prime and dy prime
as a linear combination of the map
coordinate intervals dx and dy
now the local surface coordinates on our
small nearly flat patch of curved earth
correspond to its true geometry
so the true distance between these two
locations is simply the pythagorean
relation dx prime squared plus d y prime
squared
substituting the map coordinate
expressions of these intervals into the
equation then expanding out and
collecting terms we see that we get a
new expression for the true surface
distance
but now in terms of our map coordinates
dx and dy
this means we have successfully achieved
what we set out to do at the beginning
of this video
that is describe the distance on a small
portion of the earth in terms of the
coordinate lengths dx and dy on the map
we then array the coefficients of this
expression into matrix form
these are the components of the metric
tensor
since one coefficient is counted twice
it is strictly speaking redundant and so
is termed symmetric
we also express the distance element
formula via a more concise notation
which indicates the need to sum over the
various infinitesimals and their
corresponding coefficients
this notation can be used for any number
of dimensions which is handy because in
a minute we're about to add a few
but first we can give clearer geometric
interpretation to the components of the
metric tensor
by noting that each term of the distance
element formula corresponds to a length
or angle value in the law of cosines
expression
visually this makes sense because
if instead of transforming a piece of
the surface to fit to the map
we transform a piece of the map to fit
to the surface
the right triangle formed by the map
intervals dx by dy
becomes an obtuse or acute triangle
this resizing means the length of the
map intervals are stretched or shrunk by
the square root of the value of the
metric tensor's diagonal components
while the angle between the intervals is
skewed by an amount determined via the
off-diagonal component
we can therefore view the metric tensor
in two distinct but equivalent ways
one
as encoding a description of distance
relative to a stretched and or skewed
grid
and two as a list of instructions for
resizing an infinitesimal piece of a map
in order to fit it to a surface
and both these views hold even if our
grid is a space and time grid
or our map one of space-time events
but in going from a physical manifold to
the space-time manifold
we need to recognize a few things
first that geographic locations
become space-time events
this means that space-time coordinate
intervals instead of being defined by
the span or vector between two
geographic locations are defined by the
span or vector between two world events
secondly physical distance becomes
space-time distance
meaning that our manifold invariant
instead of being defined by the distance
a local surveyor would measure traveling
between two geographic locations on the
surface of the earth
becomes defined by the space-time
distance a local observer would measure
traveling between two world events on
the space-time manifold
lastly euclidean angles in space
become hyperbolic angles in space time
now before you go panicking about having
to learn hyperbolic trigonometry
we can note that
the coordinative dx interval is defined
by the span of two nearby world events
which the map observer perceives as
being simultaneous
but a local observer in that region may
not perceive these two world events as
being simultaneous
similarly
the world events defining the span of
the coordinative dt interval
are perceived by the map observer as
being only separated in time
however a local observer may measure
them as also having spatial separation
if either of these is the case the local
observer space-time grid
may have to be skewed to fit to the map
grid
or vice versa
thus for a simplified two-dimensional
map of space-time the metric tensor
would have three components
the first would indicate to us the true
space-time distance between the world
events defining the span of the
coordinative dt interval
the second would indicate the true
space-time distance between the world
events defining the span of the
coordinative dx interval
and the third would tell us whether or
not these coordinate intervals would
retain their minkowskian orthogonality
in a local frame
one of these space-time lengths
once squared would need to be made
negative
to reflect that the formula for
space-time distance is hyperbolic
now to go to higher dimensions we need
to add in the intervals d y and d z
our two dimensional flat map thus
becomes a four dimensional flat map
and we have to consider all the ways a
four-dimensional infinitesimal
hypervolume could be stretched and or
skewed in order to be fitted to a new
geometry
four dimensions to a hyper volume means
four lengths that can be independently
resized
we can also independently skew the angle
between every pair of dimensions meaning
the angle between the t-axis and the
x-axis can be skewed the angle between
the t-axis and the y-axis can be skewed
and so forth
six skewable angles
plus four resizable lengths yields 10
total possible components
arraying these in their proper matrix
form
the four diagonal components will tell
us for any given infinitesimal piece of
a space-time observer's map
how to resize the four coordinate
lengths dt dx dy and dz
so that their new lengths correspond to
the proper space-time distance between
the world events which define their span
meanwhile the six off-diagonal
components will tell us
how much to skew the six coordinate
angles
dt dx
dtdy
dt dz
dxty
dxdz and dydz
in order to match them to their proper
space-time values
these proper space-time distances and
angles are of course the ones that would
be measured by observers local to the
system there
now it's important to note that nowhere
are the axes of space and time actually
being skewed or stretched with respect
to one another
local observers on the manifold will
always construct the four dimensions of
space and time in a normalized
orthogonal fashion
it's just that a non-local distant
observer
may end up squashing and distorting this
construction in order to fit it to their
projection
locally time and space always look the
same
but non-locally time and space are only
coordinative projections
mere gridlines drawn on a map
so at last we have a fully geometric
interpretation of the space-time metric
and indeed it's this geometric resizing
of infinitesimal pieces that allows us
finally to resolve the problem of
determining the space-time distance on a
space-time map
given any two world events on a map the
coordinate path between them and the
metric for that map the space-time
distance is easily calculated using the
metric
plus some calculus
but that's only the beginning of the
metrics real power
because analyzing how the metric changes
from point to point on our map
can tell us about the fundamental nature
of our surface
but that's for future videos
this has been dialect thanks for
watching
you